the iconic rob reiner who has become a
vocal outspoken critic of donald trump
online
joins me now rob thanks so much for
taking time out for us
thanks for having me mary
you're not just a famous director you
were also a great actor
january will mark the 50th anniversary
of all in the family the iconic sitcom
that introduced you to most of america
as a young
liberal foil to archie bunker's old
school bigotry and misogyny
did you ever imagine rob that 50 years
later you'd still be calling out archie
bunkerism
in the form of trump and trumpism
no it's it's astounding i mean we
basically have
all the issues that we dealt with racism
and
and
uh you know sexism and and all the
issues that we dealt with back in those
days
we're still wrestling with them now and
you know archie bunker
you know he's like another trump carry
he's the kind of person that would vote
for trump
there's a big difference though between
archie bunker
and and donald trump archie bunker as
as knuckleheaded as he was and as
ignorant as he was
did love his family he did care about
people he had a love for his wife
and his child donald trump is a
sociopath he doesn't care about anybody
he doesn't love anybody he has an empty
soul he only cares about himself and the
problem that we have
is that when you get somebody like that
in the white house uh
you know you we all said oh he'll
surround himself with good people and
they'll take care of it
but yeah sociopath needs people only to
take care of themselves to love
themselves so you wind up
with somebody who is bereft of any kind
of
intelligence or sophistication or
expertise around them
and you wind up people dying not just
things like uh you know threatening to
you know go after gretchen whitmer or
uh elon omar myself i was on that list
by cesar sayoc i was on that fbi
list of people that were supposed to be
targeted for a pipe bomb people can die
and when you have that coupled with
complete and utter ineptitude
when dealing with for instance the
pandemic people will
die so yes it's one thing to say oh we
got a
uh a reality tv president isn't that
funny
but it's not funny when people wind up
dead
and now we've got hundreds of thousands
of people dying
and more will die and this is a tragedy
uh beyond of of epic proportions and if
we don't get rid of them
then we won't have a democracy either
it is indeed a tragedy and you're 100
right that there's nothing funny about
it
uh you've been pretty outspoken in the
trump era uh you know
hurling all manner of names and insults
of the president you mentioned just now
he's a sociopath
uh you're understandably angry about
what's gone on over the past
four years but i do wonder have you
always been this political all of your
life
yes i've been political i've never been
this i've never been this angry though
i've never been this upset because
i've lived a long time now i'm 73 years
old
and i see our democracy slipping away i
mean we always argued
liberal versus democrat we certainly did
it on all in the family
but we never were worried that it would
be the end of democracy that this
wonderful 244-year
experiment and self-rule would be
destroyed but yes i've always been
active you know i passed legislation
that gave early childhood to to people
in california
i served for seven years on a commission
that
uh oversaw the implementation of a
of a piece of legislation that i passed
my wife and i
uh filed the first federal lawsuit that
paved the way towards marriage equality
there's a number of things that i've
been actively involved in
but this is all hands on deck i've never
seen
anything like this my father just passed
away
a few months ago and he lived till 98
and he said uh this is he never thought
in his lifetime he would see
this kind of white supremacist fascist
uh uh uh person uh take over the white
house
and he his last dying wish was that he
could vote
uh against uh donald trump and of course
he
didn't live for for that to happen but
uh i'm hoping that
we uh come together and are better
angels
and we'll rid this uh this country of
this this
horrible destructive snake oil salesman
first off let's just remind ourselves so
sorry for your loss your father was a
great man beloved to many people in this
country
and you mentioned better angels we
played a clip from the american
president a moment ago
obviously trump doesn't come anywhere
close to president andrew shepard in
that movie
but does any real-life president rob
compare to presidents
of the hollywood variety i remember
barack obama once mocked maureen dowd of
the new york times
he said she was living in a hollywood
fantasy by comparing him
to your movie and to andrew shepard
yeah no i i don't think so i mean you
know we try to
uh say this is the president we'd all
love to have
i mean when you see jimmy stewart take
to the floor of the congress
uh and filibuster in uh uh
mr smith goes to washington you know
we'd all love to have somebody
that has that kind of moral purity none
of us do
we're all flawed we're all flawed human
beings
but i look at somebody like joe biden
obviously he's not a perfect person
nobody is but he's a good person he's a
decent person
he's not a liar and he will do
what we need at this point which is to
right the ship
and get us back on the right track and
hopefully save democracy for the future
we're not going to agree with everything
that he says none of us will
but what we have now is of is is a
cancer it's a danger
and and we have to get rid of it
uh donald trump you mentioned joe biden
donald trump and joe biden will be
debating for the last time
this coming thursday uh there's a bit of
breaking news coming out the debate
commission
has just put out some new rules while
we've been on air rob saying that
they're going to allow the moderator to
mute microphones which is obviously a
response to the first
shambolic debate where chris wallace was
unable to shut donald trump up
if you were producing that debate you've
produced a lot of live events
what would you be doing to try and keep
this guy under control on thursday
are there any extra tips that you have
for the debate commission
well here's the thing first of all all
of those interruptions that he made
it only helped joe biden it made donald
trump look like a fool it made him look
desperate
and i think what would be great and i'm
you know imagining
what will be in that studio if they do
mute his mic
it's not going to shut him up it's just
going to make him more muted
and you'll hear his voice bleeding over
uh uh joe biden's mic so you'll get the
best of both worlds you'll get
to listen to joe biden and hear this
annoying human being
still ranting and raving off to the side
you directed the film lbj of course
showcasing the life of president lyndon
b johnson with
woody harrelson uh you've talked about
wanting to humanize the man who was seen
as a bully
if someone asked you to make a trump
biopic rob 10 or 20 years from now
would you do it and if so what kind of
approach would you take to that
well i'm not supposed to be saying this
because it has not been given a go-ahead
but i have an idea of not to do a biopic
specifically of trump but it's a story
that involves
uh trump's rise and also vladimir
putin's rise
and and and to kind of play those
against each other
you're the first person i've ever told
on any kind of
format that that but i'm developing uh
uh this project so
we'll see if i ever get to do it and uh
whether or not it comes to be
well thank you for letting us know we'll
look out for that because all of your
projects are always
entertaining or informative in some
shape or form one of my personal
favorite movies is a few good men i have
to say rob and i'm going to ask you this
question
it's a silly question but i'm going to
ask you anyways what do you think
colonel nathan
jessup would make of commander-in-chief
donald trump
and who do you think is the bigger
villain out of those two men
well i mean it's not even close i mean
jessup is just a
you know who uh you know he only caused
one person to die donald trump has
caused
hundreds of thousands to die so it's not
even a close call
and i got a feeling that nathan jessup
even though he believes in the chain of
command and even though
uh he will do what he is talk i believe
at some point
and this is by you know true of
anybody in in the military you're not
required
to uh uh follow an illegal order
and if trump did something illegal like
said i'm not gonna leave the white house
i'm gonna call up the national guard i'm
gonna call the military to step in
even nathan jessup would say no i'm not
doing that
rob we've got 30 seconds left so i'm
going to ask few good men my favorite
movie of all the movies you've made
what's your own favorite movie of all
the movies you've directed over the
years
well i don't know what a favorite all i
know is the one that means the most to
me
that is personally means the most is
stand by me because
i i it it it connected to my sensibility
and uh it was really a reflection of my
uh of who i am and uh and it came along
at a time when
people accepted that kind of you know
the the the the
melancholy and humor and you know and
looking back in
in the past and it's the one that means
the most to me
rob ryder thank you so much for joining
us we really appreciate it